me parece que es muy importante tener
varias formas de ver las cosas para
resolver un mismo problema por esta
razón te voy a contar otra forma de
pensar las integrales dobles hay algunos
que prefieren enseñar esta forma primero
a mí me gusta más la que ya vimos porque
ayuda a resolver los problemas pero
bueno a veces resulta útil pensarlo como
ahorita te voy a contar la diferencia es
muy sutil entonces a lo mejor ni la nota
o veas muy fácilmente porque es
equivalente por cierto alguien me mandó
un correo para decirme que estaría padre
que las pantallas se pudieran recorrer y
descubrí que esto es muy fácil de hacer
de hecho justo acabo de mover la
pantalla pero bah supongamos que tenemos
una superficie en 3-d lo de siempre me
das un punto en el plano aquí sí y
entonces yo te puedo dar la altura
queremos encontrar el volumen debajo de
la superficie entonces la nueva idea es
que podemos encontrar fácilmente el
volumen de una columna que sea muy flaca
y que esté debajo de la superficie
entonces el volumen buscado va a ser la
suma de todos estos volúmenes ya tienes
algo de experiencia visualizando en
estos dibujos así que con un poco de
imaginación creo que puedes ver a lo que
me refiero entonces vamos a esto de las
columnas comencemos por la base ahora la
base será una pequeña área en el plano
xy por aquí a esta área le llamaremos de
a supongamos que por aquí tenemos un
pequeño rectángulo algo de este estilo y
a sus lados les voy a llamar de xy deje
el de acá el de acá le voy a llamar de x
un cambio muy pequeño y del otro lado le
voy a poner de iu
como el rectángulo es pequeño sus lados
también lo son así el área de este
rectángulo va a ser de x multiplicada
por d ella va eso de ahí se encarga del
área de la base pero ahora como le
hacemos a partir de ese área para
encontrar el volumen de la columna que
se hace entre esa área que está en el
eje xy y la superficie pues podemos
multiplicar el área por la altura que es
simplemente fx y entonces lo que vamos a
obtener es un valor aproximado para para
el volumen de la columna y al final
vamos a sumar todos esos para encontrar
el volumen total déjame acabar de hacer
mi dibujo para entender un poco más que
está pasando esa de ahí es una de las
aristas de la columna esta es la segunda
arista esta de aquí es la arista frontal
y esta de la izquierda es es la última
arista y ahora déjame dibujar como
intersecta la superficie se vería más o
menos algo de este estilo algo así un
poco inclinado
y listo entonces el volumen de esta de
esta columna no es muy difícil de
calcular es igual a esta pequeña área
que le vamos a llamar de a
para entonces le voy a poner por aquí
vea
y eso hay que multiplicarlo porque pues
eso tenemos que multiplicarlo por la
altura la altura de esta columna está
dada por el valor de la función es decir
por efe de xy
ahora hay otras formas de escribir esta
expresión
otra forma es exponer vea como de x x de
g
voy a escribirlo aquí arriba es decir
podemos poner f de xy
por de x por d y como en cierta forma
aquí la multiplicación va a conmutar
también podemos escribirlo de la
siguiente forma como efe x x de x de
hecho estas tres expresiones son todas
equivalentes y representan el volumen de
la columna que se forma entre el área
que está en el eje y la superficie va
entonces si quisiéramos encontrar todo
el volumen que está debajo de la
superficie hay algunas cosas que podemos
hacer una de esas es sumar todos los
volúmenes en la dirección x es decir
fijamos una ye y sumamos todo lo de la x
ahí obtenemos una hoja muy delgada pero
ya tiene un poquito de profundidad
porque está multiplicada por un d y sale
entonces ya es una cosa con un volumen
con un volumen muy muy delgado va a
quedar déjame marcarlo por aquí para
irnos imaginando todas esas columnas
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es sumar
todas las columnas de por aquí y si
quisiéramos hacer eso qué expresión
tenemos que hacer bueno tenemos que
sumar primero con respecto a x
entonces vámonos a estar acá y lo que
tenemos que hacer es integrar podemos
escribir aquí pero se va a ser un poco
confuso porque fíjate que hay un dj que
nos dice que el day está más adentro
entonces no va a ser incorrecto pero va
a estar un poco ambiguo de qué es lo que
estamos haciendo pero aquí va a ser muy
claro vamos a sumar todas las de x
primero entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es integrar en todo el intervalo
voy a escribir expresiones pero
usualmente podemos simplemente escribir
números ahorita va a ser para que sea
más claro voy a poner x igualada como
límite inferior y como el límite
superior voy a poner x igual a b es
decir aquí voy a escribir x igual a b
eso lo que nos va a dar va uno va a ser
un pequeño volumen dejando una fija que
está paralelo al plano x z
una vez que tenemos esa rebanada que ya
tiene un poquito de volumen tenemos que
integrar todas esas rebanadas para
encontrar el volumen total ya se empieza
a parecer mucho a lo que hicimos en los
vídeos pasados es decir
aquí le voy a poner de iu
entonces ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es sumar todos todos los valores que
obtenemos con respecto a y entonces voy
a tomar la integral desde igual a este
límite que ese entonces ya igual hace y
el límite superior es de igual a d
baja
una vez que evaluemos toda esta
expresión vamos a haber obtenido el
volumen de este sólido de aquí ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa si lo hacemos al
revés es decir vamos a pensarlo primero
fijando y vamos a empezar primero
fijando un valor de x entonces en vez de
en vez de sumar todos los valores con
respecto a x y obtener una hoja vamos a
sumar todos los valores de primero y
vamos a encontrar vamos a encontrar otra
vez una hoja con cierto volumen pero
ahora es paralela al plano de z va a
quedar algo de este estilo acuérdate que
ya tiene un poco de profundidad porque
ya está x de x entonces hay que integrar
vamos a integrar primero con respecto a
y es decir desde y igual a c
hasta he igualado
y luego eso nos va a dar el volumen así
flaquito de esta área de aquí y lo que
queremos hacer es sumar todas esas todas
esas rebanadas que le hicimos al sólido
y para eso ahora tenemos que mover los
valores en x es decir ahora tenemos que
integrar tenemos que hacer una nueva
integral
y nuestros límites inferiores y
superiores cuáles van a ser pues saber
aquí abajo va a ser x igual a a
y tenemos que terminar en x b una vez
más me va a dar el volumen entonces
fíjate esto ya se parece mucho a lo que
hicimos en los vídeos pasados otra vez
tenemos de quite y entonces vamos
integrando rebanadas del sólido pero
ahora vamos a esta expresión de acá lo
que pasa con de a es que es una
abreviación entonces muchas veces en
libros de física se usa esto fíjate se
usa la doble integral sobre el dominio
esta de indica que estamos integrando en
el plano xy sobre una región que se
llama d es una región que es de dos
dimensiones y hay que integrar fx y x de
a la razón por la cual quiero enseñarte
esta anotación es que la usan en libros
de física todo el tiempo a mí no me
gusta mucho ok estoy de acuerdo que es
una abreviación y se ve un poco más
simple pero lo que me pasa es que cuando
encuentro una expresión que no sé cómo
evaluar entonces me puede ser un poco
confusa
déjame darte un poco más de detalles si
la región d es un rectángulo entonces en
el fondo el de a es lo mismo que esto o
esto es decir de aes o un de equis de i
o bien puede ser un de de x la única
diferencia es que en las notaciones de
acá tenemos un cierto orden aquí abajo
es decir a qué me refiero con esto pues
lo que dijimos hace rato
primero fijamos una equis o bien primero
fijamos una ye y hacemos integrales de
superficies cuando usamos la anotación
nueva lo que nos dice es que es una
doble integral en una región de dos
dimensiones pero esta región no tiene
por qué ser un rectángulo a lo mejor de
es un círculo o una región más rara esta
es otra razón por la cual se use esta
anotación nos da la libertad de integrar
demás formas por ejemplo podemos usar
coordenadas polares o podemos integrar
de varias otras formas más pero bueno
simplemente quería darte una nueva forma
de agarrar la intuición a esto de hacer
integrales dobles estas tres expresiones
finalmente son lo mismo esta última se
va a usar más en libros de física como
nota algunas veces este d lo vas a ver
como una s que quiere decir superficie
estamos usando rectángulos todo el
tiempo lo cual es muy fácil pero después
se va a volver un poco más complicado
saleh ya se me está acabando el tiempo
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo